yeah yeah yeah this is all ukraine and  this is all putin's fault  what they don't show you is they don't  show you a chart of what happened to gas  prices over the year  prior to any of us hearing about knowing  about understanding a problem in ukraine  they're trying to say that all of those  problems  were caused by russia  oh [ __ ] this guy he thinks joe biden  invented gas prices like gasoline and  gas prices just started just when joe  biden became president it's not like  only american only american gasoline is  rising  all around the world is plummeting in  prices joe biden though he's pushing the  gasoline button on his desk he's turning  up the gasoline prices cause that's how  it [ __ ] work get the [ __ ] out of here  with this [ __ ] all because some dumb  [ __ ] seen a sticker on a gas  pump that said joe biden did that how do  they believe this crackhead really  honestly how do they do it a little less  coke there donny